JAGAN ATHREYA: Hello, and
welcome to the session
on best practices to maximize
BigQuery performance.
My name is Jagan Athreya,
and I'm a product manager
for BigQuery Google.
I'm pleased to be
joined in this session
by Gary Steelman, who is a
software engineer at Twitter.
Hello, Gary.
GARY STEELMAN: Hey, Jagan,
nice to be here today.
JAGAN ATHREYA: Really
glad to have you.
We've put together
a technical session
for data analysts, data
engineers, and data scientists.
In short, if you like SQL,
you've come to the right place.
I'm going to start with a
quick overview of the BigQuery
architecture that drives
the performance you
see in BigQuery.
Then we'll walk
through a typical query
execution within BigQuery.
Next, we'll cover some of the
best practices of how to write
fast and efficient queries.
And we'll also cover data
processing techniques
on the best ways to
get data into BigQuery.
Then I will turn
it over to Gary,
who will show you how Twitter
uses BigQuery and will share
some of his performance tips.
Shall we dive in?
Customers around the world
rely on BigQuery performance
to run their business.
Spotify, which is a global
leader in music streaming,
analyzes hundreds
of petabytes of data
to give you the most
personalized song
recommendations.
Their analytical queries went
from 16 minutes to 33 seconds
after moving to BigQuery.
HSBC is a global financial
institution serving
40 million customers worldwide.
They were able to speed up their
country liquidity calculations
from hours to minutes and run
their financial crime analysis
10 times faster with BigQuery.
UPS, the largest package
delivery company in the world,
collects a billion data
points into BigQuery every day
and have used it to
optimize the truck routes,
saving $400 million and
10 million gallons of fuel
each year.
So let's explore
how BigQuery can
help drive performance
for these businesses
and businesses such as yours.
So what makes BigQuery special?
It starts with the
true separation
of storage and compute, which
allows you to store petabytes
of data in storage,
but pay pennies
per day for your queries.
Data is stored in Colossus,
which is BigQuery's columnar
storage, which is encrypted,
replicated, and distributed,
making it highly durable
against failures.
When you send your
queries to BigQuery,
they run in stages over a
massive farm of compute units
called slots, which are units
of computational capacity.
BigQuery automatically
calculates how many
stages are needed
for every query
and dynamically calculate the
slots needed for each stage.
Data moves from the
storage to the query server
at lightning speed over
the petabit scale network
called Jupiter network.
Even complex queries,
which need to store
data between the query stages,
have a persistent store
called shuffle, which
is entirely in memory.
All of these put
together is what
makes BigQuery deliver blazing
fast performance to you.
Now we'll take a look
at a sample query
to see how it works within
the BigQuery architecture.
This is an example
of a scan filter
aggregate query on a table
containing one billion page
view logs from Wikipedia where
the title contains Google.
The queries are first routed
to a query master, which
contacts the metadata
server to figure out
exactly where the
physical data resides
and how it's partitioned to come
up with the initial execution
plan.
The first stage of this
query sends the query
to a lot of parallel
workers, each of which
reads the title
column and filters out
the data that don't match.
It then does a
partial aggregation
as directed by the GROUP
BY, and writes the results
into shuffle using
a hash of the title.
The next stage reads
from the shuffled output
from the previous stage and
does the final aggregation.
The final stage, or stage
3, is extremely simple.
It just reads the
resulting titles
and sorts them in an
alphabetical descending order.
This final sort operation
is done on a single worker
for serving up the results
to the [INAUDIBLE]..
Now that we know how
BigQuery runs queries,
let's look at some of
the best practices on how
to run these queries fast and
efficient within BigQuery.
A typical query
consists of a select,
from, where, group by,
and order by clauses.
Since BigQuery is
a columnar store,
we're going to start out
with how to optimize select.
Select star may actually
drive up your costs
if you have a really wide
table with lots of columns.
So the first tip
I have for you is
to use only the necessary
columns in your select clause,
instead of select star.
Next, when using
functions, consider
using approximate functions,
such as approx_count_distinct
or approximate
quantiles, instead
of the corresponding
exact functions,
such as count_distinct
or quantiles.
These are approximate
functions produce results
which are 99% accurate if
you're looking for trend data
and not [? to import ?] exact
values, such as financial data.
Now, we'll come
to where the where
clauses, where you can drive
a lot of query optimization
and efficiency.
The key to improving
efficiency is
to filter early and
use predicates, which
can be pushed down into the
tables to filter out data,
especially when joining
multiple tables.
Use the column directly to
match values is a lot more
efficient than applying a
function on a column master
value, since this predicate
can be pushed down.
Next, we'll come to joins in
the where clause, any complex
query involving joining
one or more tables
and finding matching
relationships
through the JOIN columns.
There are different types of
joins, such as inner join,
cross join, left and right
join, which are well-known.
Speaking of how
they're executed,
joins are executed in
BigQuery in several ways,
a broadcast join is where
a large table on the left
is joined with a small table
on the right of the join.
In BigQuery, a broadcast
join takes the small table
and sends the entire table
to every worker working
on the large table
column values,
if the table on the right
is sufficiently small.
To achieve this
efficiency, you may
need to filter and aggregate
the data from the small table
before joining with
the large tables.
The other type of join
executor within BigQuery
is a hash join, where
you're joining large tables.
Now, this is computationally
more intensive.
The goal of the hash
join optimization
is to ensure balanced
data distribution
across the join tables.
So keep an eye
out for data skew.
To give an example of
data skew, the number
of cricket players per capita
is skewed to the 12 member
countries of the
International Cricket
Council versus the countries
in the rest of the world.
When this happens, you may
need to query the skewed data
separately from the
other data and combine
the results using
union, to maximize
the efficiency of the query.
A special case of
join is self join,
when a data is
joined with itself.
This type of query can
get very expensive.
Some of the techniques you can
use to get the data efficiently
is to first take one pass at it.
So for example, if you
have a table containing
male and female baby names,
you can use an if function
to create pseudo columns and
compute both sets of aggregates
in one pass.
Another option if you have
multiple records with dependent
data-- for example, a start
and end time and date for bike
rides--
you can use the lead
and lag functions
to specify a window within
which you [INAUDIBLE]
to find the matching entry.
To understand how
these queries work,
it is important to look at
the actual execution plan.
The execution plan
for the query is
available under the execution
details for every query
in the BigQuery user interface.
It shows you the
stages that the query
took and provides the
details of the operations
and timings of each stage.
Look for the waits, which
indicates the stage that
is waiting for a dependent
stage to complete,
which can often be
a source of delay.
Also look for variances between
the average and maximum worker
timings.
This indicates that
the distribution
of work across the workers
may not be uniform.
Now that you've identified
query inefficiencies,
what can you do to improve them?
BigQuery provides several
data organization techniques,
such as partitioning
and clustering,
to speed up your query
and lower the cost.
Partitioning in
BigQuery allows you
to divide large tables into
smaller logical tables called
partitions.
Data for one partition
is stored in a physically
separate location from
the other partitions,
each with its own metadata.
When a query is
issued representing
a specific partition
value, BigQuery only
scans those logical tables
matching the partition value,
instead of the entire table.
Partitions are usually designed
for low cardinality fields,
such as fields with a low number
of distinct values-- generally
of the order of a few thousand.
Clustering is a different
form of storage optimization
within BigQuery that stores the
data in a semi-sorted format
based on the cluster
key, which make
consistent one or more columns.
You can use a combination of
partitioning and clustering
to optimize your
query by identifying
the low cardinality and
high cardinality columns
as candidates for
partitioning and clustering.
We recently announced
support for partitioning
of non-partitioned tables,
so you can speed up
key look-ups for even
high-cardinality data which
are not partitioned,
such as user IDs.
In addition to
looking up queries,
you can also improve them cost
efficiency of DML operations
through partition pruning, by
using the underscore partition
time pseudo column for
ingested time partition tables
or by using the table
timestamp column for partition
tables in your DML statement.
The final recommendation
for query speed
up is the use of Materialized
Views and BI Engine.
Materialized Views
are pre-computed views
at cache results of a query
for increased performance
and efficiency.
BigQuery leverages these
pre-computed results
from Materialized Views
to deliver the results.
If the data changes, BigQuery
only reads the delta changes
from the base table to compute
the latest results, which
is much more efficient.
BigQuery is also smart enough to
detect when a query can benefit
from a Materialized View
and automatically redirects
the query to the cached results
for a Materialized View,
instead of querying the
base table from storage.
BI Engine takes the speed
improvements up another level
by providing an in-memory
store for BigQuery.
To enable this, just reserve
the BI Engine memory capacity
in the same location as your
data set, and that's it.
Your queries will now run
fast and always fresh.
To store and manage
data, you need
to bring data into BigQuery.
BigQuery supports batch
and streaming methods
of data ingest.
Data can be loaded into
BigQuery from a variety
of storage formats,
ranging from Avro to JSON.
You can even use DML to
perform ELT to transform
data using BigQuery API.
We've removed the limits
of the number of DMLs
a table can process
per day, which
is much more beneficial to you
now and is much more useful.
If you need to perform
continuous ingest,
you'll need to use the streaming
API to get more real time
information.
If you need really accurate data
that is still in the streaming
buffer or partition tables, you
can use an additional clause
of underscore partition
time, as now defined
the data that is in the buffer.
Finally, we come to
automation within BigQuery.
While we have various ETL
tools such as Cloud Composure
and Data Fusion to form
various types of ETL,
sometimes it may be more
efficient to use BigQuery
to run complex ETL operations.
BigQuery supports
scripting, by which
you can run a series of
commands in a specified
sequence with control
logic, such as while and if.
And if you want
to save these, you
can save these as
a reusable program
called a stored procedure.
It can also be used
for migrating existing
stored procedures
from legacy databases
to bring them into BigQuery.
This allows you to perform your
in-data warehouse operations
quickly, without having
the overhead of having
to move that data outside.
With this, let me now
turn it over to Gary
to tell us how BigQuery best
practices are used at Twitter.
GARY STEELMAN: Thank you, Jagan.
My name is Gary, and I'm a
software engineer at Twitter.
Today I going to talk about
how we use BigQuery at Twitter
and some of the specific
use cases we have,
and some of the
performance results
that we've seen from using
BigQuery's optimization
features.
So first, I want to go ahead
and just dive right in and talk
about how we use
BigQuery at Twitter.
It's important to understand
the scale at which we
use BigQuery at Twitter.
We have hundreds of different
users running queries and jobs
every month.
They're running tens of
thousands of jobs every day,
most of which are queries.
We store data and run queries
in hundreds of different GCP
projects, with thousands
of different data sets
storing hundreds of
petabytes of data.
As you might imagine,
processing that amount of data
uses a lot of compute
power, and we're
using over a million
slot hours a day.
It's important to note
that at this scale
at Twitter, that's why we care
about performance so much.
Every little bit of performance
optimization we can make
helps quite a lot.
So now let me talk about some
of the different actual use
cases we have for
BigQuery at Twitter.
We can think of these broadly
in two different categories,
analytics projects
and adoption projects.
The analytics projects you see
here I'll get into a little bit
more detail later.
But the adoption
projects are ones
that we can think of as
already existing and migrating
from a previous platform
over to BigQuery.
So for example, people are
migrating from Google Sheets
and Google Apps scripts--
or on premise Vertica
and Solr clusters,
or even using Google Analytics
and moving their use cases
to BigQuery.
Teams who are
adopting BigQuery are
looking for big
gains in performance
and also maintainability.
They're also looking for
that rich integration
with GCP tooling.
So now, let me talk a little bit
about those analytics projects
in more detail and some
of the performance gains
that we've seen for those
analytics use cases.
It's important to
frame this discussion
by understanding how we look at
these optimizations at Twitter.
We look at them at
three different levels,
the query level, the table
level, and the project level.
And a lot of those
different features
that you saw Jagan
talk about earlier you
can see here categorized into
the different categories.
We make heavy use of all
of these optimizations,
because at our scale at Twitter,
every little bit counts.
We also use the project
level optimizations
quite a bit, such as slot
reservations and workload
isolation.
We try to separate workloads
into separate projects,
so we don't end up with
noisy neighbor problems.
So now that we have
an overview of how
we think about these
features at Twitter,
let's talk about how
we actually use them
in some of these different
types of products.
The first one I'll
talk about today
is this marketing product.
The goal of this product is to
generate an internal dashboard
based on some filters, where
the results of this report
will actually be used to
drive marketing insights
and strategies internally.
Generating this report requires
running multiple BigQuery
queries for each of
the different sections
of the report.
So here, are some of
the first optimizations
we made were to partition
the input tables by time
and to give the project
more query slots to use.
These two steps, partitioning
the input tables by time
and giving the project
more query slots,
are generally our very
first two steps every time.
The reason is because
these are very low effort
and very high impact steps.
We will do this
across most projects.
Here, we also clustered the
input tables by user IDs,
because that's what
the report is keyed on.
And we also scheduled the
projection of necessary columns
out of the source tables and
into a destination table.
In that destination
table, we also
join in a couple of
additional columns,
just so all of the data
for this particular report
is available in one
table, ready to go.
Having all your data
in one table like that
is actually a huge speed
up just in and of itself.
As part of this, we
also helped this team
clean up their queries by making
small tweaks here and there,
such as removing unnecessary
order by clauses.
All of these things
together resulted
in a 33% faster average query
time, and a 45% faster end
to end report generation
time for this use case.
The next use case that
I'll talk about today
is the A/B
experimentation project.
This team already has
an analytics use case
running on premise in Vertica.
So in this case, we're migrating
from an on-premise Vertica
cluster into BigQuery.
The goal of this
use case is to fetch
the results of A/B experiments
on the Twitter product
and render those in a UI.
Users of the UI
will actually use
the insights they gain from the
UI to drive product decisions.
The interesting thing here
is that the table that
powers this UI has high
hundreds of terabytes
of data in one place.
We also have a very low
latency requirement,
because this is powering
an internal dashboard.
So here, we partitioned these
input tables by time again
and gave it more query
slots to execute.
Again, we do this for
almost every project.
We also clustered these
tables by more than one ID.
Like Jagan mentioned, you can
cluster by more than one field.
And we wanted to do this in
order of highest cardinality
first to eliminate the
most amount of data
in a query as possible.
We also selected only
the necessary columns out
of these source tables, whereas
the Vertica query before was
selecting all of the columns.
And finally, one of the
more interesting performance
optimizations we made was
using an array aggregation
clause in BigQuery, where
in Vertica we had been
using a row number over clause.
We use this to identify the
most recent row in a set of rows
to populate part of this UI.
All of these things
together ended up
speeding up the queries by 55%.
And the final project
that I'll talk about today
is a Tweet analytics project.
For this project, we
want to generate a report
of recent actions on entities.
The interesting
thing about this one
is that we're migrating from
an on-premise Solr cluster
into BigQuery, and
also the BigQuery table
is populated by
BigQuery streaming.
The table is also massive.
It's multiple petabytes
of data in a single table.
Here too, we partitioned
the input tables by time,
and we gave the project
many, many more queries slots
to work with.
We also scheduled a projection
of the necessary columns
to generate this report
out of the source tables
into a destination table again.
Here too, we also saw a
nice speed up with that.
The most interesting
thing that we saw here,
though, is we had to tune
our storage set sizes.
BigQuery tables are backed by
storage sets, which contain
files, which contain records.
Storage sets have a
maximum size limit.
So when a storage set
fills up with records,
it actually gets committed
and creates a metadata entry
with it associated
with the table.
When a query wants
to run on a table,
it has to process
all the metadata
for the different storage sets
to decide which storage sets
actually need to be accessed.
If there's a lot
of storage sets,
there's a lot of
metadata entries.
And processing a lot
of metadata entries
can actually slow
down your query.
So in our use case, we worked
with Google engineering
to increase the size
of our storage sets.
Larger sized storage sets means
fewer storage sets overall,
because each one can
hold more records.
Because there are
fewer storage sets,
there is less metadata entries
for a query to have to process,
which actually
ends up speeding up
your query a good
amount when you
have a high volume of
streaming inserts into a table.
All of these
optimizations together
resulted in 33% faster
queries for this use case.
And that's the last use case
I going to talk about today.
I want to give a huge shout
out to everyone at Twitter,
cross functionally,
at Google PSO,
and Google Engineering
for all the help
that they've given up to today.
Google has helped us build
additional tools for Twitter
internal data format.
They've helped us build
dashboards and administration
tools.
They've helped us increase
the DML efficiency by changing
things in the back end.
And they've increased limits in
GCP all over the place for us.
Some of the most notable
ones are for VPCSC
or for the amount of data
that a particular query
can process in a single go.
Without all of these
things together,
we wouldn't be near
where we are today.
And we're really looking forward
to continuing our adoption
and growth with
BigQuery at Twitter.
So thank you to everyone
who's been involved.
I'll pass it back
over to Jagan now,
so he can wrap up the
rest of this presentation.
JAGAN ATHREYA: I hope you've
found this session useful,
and some of the performance
tips and techniques
that we've shared
with you today.
I want to thank my
co-presenter Gary, who
shared his best practices of
using BigQuery at Twitter,
and I want to thank you
for watching this session.